away from the iconic sites of Kremlin
and Red Square it's here in the suburbs
where protesters are planning their next
move they accuse the Kremlin of
interference and trying to rig the City
Council election in favor of the
candidates of the ruling party United
Russia thousands have been arrested but
they say that won't stop them only time
will show how people will react to the
authorities actions and personally
afraid but we are full of fears if we
let the fear control us we aren't really
living life is when we are calm our
fears and I understand the risks to me
and my family but I don't see how to
resolve this issue in any other way to
understand what people want you have to
give them choice the Moscow City Council
is an administrative body not a
political one and its elections rarely
trigger controversy this time it's
different the banning of opposition
candidates by the government is angered
Moscow white sand that's spilling out
onto the streets maria lipman is a
political analyst and says the
government crackdown is designed to
prevent the public becoming aware of the
protests and from its spreading
nationwide everything at their disposal
is unfortunately sounds like a real
prospect right now the government is
showing determination to use more
violence harder violence though the
policy gets harder on a daily basis
the chance of this protest to become
nationwide is I would say zero the
police say the arrests were for Public
Order offenses and necessary to maintain
public order according to the police
more than a thousand people were
detained last week and more are expected
this Saturday to reach a good cop one of
the opposition politicians barred from
running has been arrested for calling
for protests he appeared at an appeal at
the Moscow City Court on Thursday and
it's not just him in this barn behind me
is another opposition politician that
wants to run for the City Council but
has been barred now given that everybody
is expecting Saturday's protests to be
even larger than they were the previous
week expect to see more scenes like this
outside of court come Monday
Imran Khan al Jazeera Moscow